こんにちは　はじめしゃちょーです
ただいま　銭湯を貸し切りに
しております
はいというわけで今回の企画なんですけれども
これはもうこっかな（小声）
皆さま　サウナ　入ったことありますでしょうか
サウナって言うのは　基本的には暑くて　長い時間いるものではないんですよ
なんですけれども　サウナに入ってる間は
汗をかくことができて
発汗作用
汗をかいて体の毒素をだしたり
これなんか痩せるにつながるんですよ
なんでサウナ……サウナ長い時間皆さん入っていたいとは思うんですけども
長い時間いれないのがサウナの弱点！
で、今回そのサウナに長い時間いれない弱点を克服され
てゅるれぷしゅあ(噛んだ）
今回サウナに短い時間しかいれないという弱点を克服するために
こちらを準備しました
はい！こちら
えー It's so cool & so …warm！？
暖かいの！？
暖かいのこれ！？
えーとなんかこれ　ネットで見たんですけども
身につけるエアコンらしいです
いつでも自分だけの”快適さを身にまとう”
エレクトリック・スカーフ
なんか、電気的なスカーフ
エレクトリック・スカーフをつけることによって
エアコンがない場所でもエアコンの状態が味わえるというものでございます
サウナに長い時間いると熱中しょうがいになってしまうんですけども
（なんかいるみたいな効果音）
今回はこの
体に身につけるエアコンを身につけることによって
（ぽんっという効果音）
サウナにいる人間の限界をこれをつけてこえてみようかと、思います。
温泉で開封っていうのが面白いよね
やー結構でもハイテクらしくて
へー
ほらほらほらほら
た：えっすごいじゃん
これですね
近未来ですよたぶん
なんか新型のエアコンらしいですもん
このみためがちょういかついです
VRみたいだよね
はいというわけでちょっと完成したので一回つけてみましょう
これでたぶんつい…てますよね？
わっうわあつっ！あつう！あつぅ！
まって！あつっ！あつい！
今絶対暖房がきいてる？これ
あっ　今　あのね青くなったよ
ま、青だったらエアコン説があるのではないでしょうか。
あつい！
なんかつけてから2分間くらいはちょっと動かさなきゃいけないみたいなんで
ちょっと待ってみます
た：いきますよー
た：はい！
あっ
ぅあっ　冷たいね！　た：冷たいね！
冷たい　冷たい　冷たい
ひんやりしてる
なんだろ？風がきてんのかな？
これならきっと
常人がいるサウナの限界の時間を
こえれると思うので
彼が普通にサウナに入っていただいて
僕が身体につけるエアコンをつけたままで
どれぐらい長い時間サウナにいれるかを
検証していきたいと思います
ではいこう
（効果音）
（銭湯っぽいBGM）
（痛そうな効果音）
はい　ババンバ　バンバンバーンっと
はい　ババンバ　バンバンバンと
（どどんっという効果音）
うわ！！あっづ！！ヴあっつ！！
♪ｴﾝﾃﾞｨﾝｸﾞ♪
はぁぁ　あっつあっつ
あっついあっついあっついあっつい
無理無理無理
ちょっとまって　まって（息を吸い込む）
金属的な暑さがすごかった